belong now the clock of the long now is
about planning for the long term and
thinking in the long term in a world in
which people appear to be thinking in
the shorter and shorter term tongs evoke
concluded you couldn't actually create a
story that would last 10,000 years you
could only create a story that would
last for three generations for ourselves
for our children for their children
I think is try and create stories but it
interesting
but our grandchildren might want to tell
those stories to their grandchildren
because that's the purpose of Storace
its what therefore make life worth
living and sometimes they keep us alive
[Music]